ذكرت شبكة سي إن إن حصريًا يوم الجمعة أن
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي يحقق في اختراق جزء
من شبكة الكمبيوتر الخاصة به
تحديدًا الجزء الذي
يستخدمه المكتب للتحقيق في استغلال صور جنسية للأطفال ،
لذا فهذه
مسألة خطيرة للغاية حاول مسؤولو مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي في الأيام الأخيرة
معالجتها.  لقد
قاموا بعزل الحادث لمنع
البرامج الضارة من الانتشار داخل
الشبكة ولا يزال
الوضع متطورًا إلى حد كبير ما نعرفه وما
لا
نعرفه في هذه المرحلة هو من نفذ
هذا  الاختراق أو لماذا ما نعرفه هو أن
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي (FBI) صارم للغاية بشأن
هذا الأمر وقد لا يقدم أي
تحديثات عامة ما لم
يزعج تقريرنا بعض التحديثات وما
يمكننا قوله هو أنك تعلم أن هذا
نوع من السخرية  الموقف لأن مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي الذي تتصل به عادةً عندما
تتعرض للاختراق ، لذا يتعين على مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي اللجوء
داخليًا إلى خبرائه لمحاولة الوصول
إلى قاع الولايات المتحدة ومعالجتها